- L'hiver est doux,
heureusement, vous diront
À Boutcha, en banlieue de Kiev,
c'est ironiqueseseseseseseseses.
"Presque tous les jours, dit-
elle, ils costststststststststsr
parce qu'il fait très froid."
Quand on se retrouve entre
voisines autour des flammes,
du courage.
"C'est fatigant mais on se sent
réchauffésosososos soldats, dit
Diana, qui se battent pour nous.
Et nous avons qu'eux sont
réchauononononononononononononor
sur notre sort."
de Crimée en octobre, la Russie
multiplie les salves de missiles
sur les infrastructures
énergétiques civiles.
Au moins huit attaques majeures
ont privé des nsnsnsns
d'Ukrainiens d'électricité,
d'eau et de chauffage.nvnvnvnviu
de distribution électrique
est endommagée : il doit êtreins
de courant régulière.
(sirène)
Dans la région de Kiev, entre
30 et 50 % des foyers sont
sans électricité à un moment
ou à un autre.
selon le directeur général
d'un important fournisseur
d'électricité en Ukraine.
"Nous sommes convainc
qu'il y aura d'autres attaques,
qu'il y aura d'autres dommages,
dit-il, mais nous lolololololols
vont continuer à réparer
le réseau élec."."."."
En moins de deux mois,
ces employés ont rplplplplus de
1800 km de lignes électriques.
Le réseau, parfois désuet,
ne tolère ps s s s s s s s s s t
à Kiev, Vadim et son équipe
répondent aux appels incessantsr
rétablir le courant.
"Parfois, j'ai des moments
de découragement, admet Vadim,
mais ils sont brefs.
de faire quelque chose et
je dois le faire parce que
quand je suis à la maison
sans électricité, je smomomomom,
alors je fais de mon mieux
pour eux."
Pour cr r r r leurs habitations,
la majorité des gens ici
dépendent d'un système central
da. . . . . . . . . . . . . . .s
ukrainiennes ne peuvent plus
enenenenter le systèmevec
de l'eau chaude et doivent
prendre la décision de drainer
les canaux pour éviter que
les tuyaux n'éclatent.
Autrement dit, pas de chauffage
de l'hiver alors queatteindre ls
la cuisine qu'on concentre
les activité y y y y fait
plus chaud. Nikita, 8 ans, fait
ses devoirs sous l'oeil attentif
de Nadia, sa grand....
Elle s'inquiète que l'école,
soit encore plus froide que
la maison. Mais lui le remarque
à peine, trop heureux de
ne plus étudier en ligne.
"Même si c'est froid,
J'ai un bon chandail et je porte
une combinaison dess
Pour tromper l'ennui et
le froid, on accumule
s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s ,
sous plusieurs en fait,
et on se réfugie dans le sommeil
Paul'a'a'a'arrière-grand-mère,
s'accommode très bien
de l'inconfort.
"Après ce que j'ai enduré
pourquoi je partirais?"
Ce qu'elle a enduré, c'était
l'occupation des Russes, d d d e
sang-froid. Elle dort peut-être
trop, mais maintenant au moins,
elle le fait sur
ses deux oreilles.
-C-C-C-C-C-C-C-C-C-C-C-C-C-C-C-a